nous voici aux centres de dépouillement
de la pétition contre le mariage pour
tous aux chaînés lundi soir la barre des
500 mille signatures le nombre requis
pour saisir le conseil économique social
et environnemental était franchi 5 152
mille signatures exactement et quand on
voit cette soixantaine de bénévoles qui
s'activent le chiffre risque encore de
grands pays on en arrive tous les jours
tous les jours il ya surtout des gens
qui apportent des paquets entiers
hier on avait vu débarquer de l'avion
une personne avec une grande valise qui
venait de la martinique avec je crois
7000 pétition comme martin aurieng vient
tous les jours et des acomptes et est
classé les signatures cette salle
municipale prêtait au collectif la manif
pour tous est devenue sa deuxième maison
comme beaucoup de ses volontaires à la
le sentiment de participer à un combat
citoyen le but c'est de faire entendre
notre voix la voix de tous les français
et pas juste une élite de paris et
quelques lobbyistes bien financé c'est
la révolte citoyenne
c'est aujourd'hui le pouvoir va passer
dans la rue
on risque peut-être la manif pour tous
d'être le premier parti politique en
france
vendredi devant le cse c'est en effet la
première fois que le cce le conseil
économique social et environnemental a
été saisie par pétition
le collectif a rendez vous vendredi
matin signature sous le bras ou plutôt
dans plusieurs camions si le compte est
validé le saison aura un an pour rendre
son avis et pour avoir plus de poids le
collectif a décidé de poursuivre le
comptage jusqu'à la prochaine réunion du
cce le 26 février
on dépassera largement le million de
révision et là vraiment on aura un
observatoire du mékong en français sera
pas pour les marginaux
malgré cette mobilisation le projet de
loi avancé poursuit son agenda
l'assemblée nationale doit voter la loi
aujourd'hui le sénat quant à lui
l'examinera le 2 avril